yvan colonna pourra t'il se rendre à la
justice on avocats n'excluent pas
entièrement cette hypothèse et plaide
pour une éventuelle reddition de celui
qui est soupçonné de l'assassinât du
préfet erignac stefan rheinert il signe
yvan colonna patriotes recherché en
fuite depuis deux ans l'assassin présumé
du préfet erignac a choisi d'écrire pour
se manifester en langue corse
il prétend n'être pour rien dans
l'assassinât du préfet puis il affirme
clairement la justice française au
service de l'éradication du mouvement
national je ne pense pas un instant le
mettre entre ses mains pour yvan colonna
donc pas question d'une reddition
pourtant c'est ce que réclament
aujourd'hui son avocat mais sous
certaines conditions
moi je 2 je dois lui demander de se
rendre si je peux garantir en tant que
défenseur les conditions d'un procès
équitable dont un juge impartial
indépendant il serait préférable pour
lui que il se présente pour se défendre
et pour contester les charges de
l'accusation
la lettre adressée à l'hebdomadaire
nationalistes ou ribombu a été
authentifié par sa famille mais pas
encore par la police une missive qui a
le don d'exaspérer les politiques
jean pierre chevènement a qualifi vent
colonna de lâches
la ministre de la justice attend elle
devoir colonna devant les joueurs encore
personne n'a réagi
seul françois santoni ancienne figure du
nationalisme y voit un message clair sur
fond d' amnistie
je crois qu'ils seront au bon souvenir
des nationalistes quelque part on a dû
promettre au menu le promettent comme
aux autres un une éventuelle amnistie
moi je m'en tiens à ce qu'écrit l'on
connaît il ya deux jours savoir qu'il ne
se rendrait pas je pense que ce serait
la décision la plus judicieuse pour lui
aujourd'hui
six des sept membres du commando présumé
responsable de l'assassinât du préfet
sont sous les verrous
yvan colonna lui pour toujours
on